we sent victoria out in the elements to
let us know what's going on now near
kyle canyon let's head on over to
victoria live right now victoria good
evening
hey ted well the cold rain started but i
stopped excuse me but we've got some
really light flurries coming down we're
just about four thousand feet up high in
elevation you can see cars are coming
here but they are driving very slow
they're all going up the mountain and
just up just at 5000 feet like you
mentioned snow is coming down and we
know for las vegas residents the word
snow excites a lot of people we tried
going up there ourselves but we couldn't
because the flashes were on telling
everyone that they needed to put on
those chains on your tires that's super
important to know because if you go up
there and you don't have chains on your
tires you're going to be redirected to
go all the way back down again i'm going
to have my photog show you the car is
coming back coming up here we've been
seeing a lot of these cars coming right
back down as i as i mentioned before
because you will not be able to move any
further if you don't have chains and
your tires back out here live reporting
from
kyle cannon excuse me victoria saha live
local now